Про гігантські поклади газу в Україні провідомив
прем'єр-міністр Володимир Гройсман.
В Україні покладів газу по всім дослідженням різних
авторитетних організацій, ми на другому-
третьому місці в світі по покладам...
Чи так це?
Через день після цієї заяви прес-служба
українського прем"єра, відповідаючи на запит DW,
заявила: Гройсман обмовився, бо мав на увазі
не весь світ, а лише Європу.
Щоправда, офіційного спростування так і не було.
За даними міністерства енергетики США, найбільші
родовища блакитного палива має Росія, поклади
якої оцінили у 49 трильйонів кубометрів. На другому
та третьому місці Іран та Катар. Україна - на 24-й
сходинці у світі з однією цілою однією десятою трильйона кубометрів.
Але навіть якщо премєр мав на увазі лише Європу,
то на які саме "всі авторитетні дослідження" він
посилався, у прес-службі Гройсмана нам не відповіли.
Утім, авторитетних міжнародних досліджень
не так вже й багато.
Тож, ДВ перевірила, чи підтверджують вони тезу,
що Україна - в топ-трійці Європи за газовими покладами.
Окремих рейтингів щодо родовищ виключно в Європі немає.
Деякі дослідження виділяють Європу і Євразію в окрему групу.
Так, приміром, у останній доповіді British Petroleum
про глобальні тенденції в енергетичному секторі
за 2016-й рік, якщо не врахувати країн Центральної Азії,
Україна опиняється на четвертому місці після Росії,
Норвегії та Нідерландів. Українські газові поклади
оцінюють у 0,6 трильйона кубометрів.
Схожа картина в аналогічному звіті OPEC, де
Україну теж занесено до групи країн Євразії.
Тут українські родовища оцінюють у 0,9 трильйона
кубометрів і вона серед європейських країн
опиняється на третьому місці - після Росії та Норвегії.
Україна точно не друга-третя у світі за покладами газу.
Проте можна сказати, що посідає друге-третє місце у Європі,
якщо не враховувати російських родовищ,
які розташовані переважно на азійській території РФ.
Але самі лише газові поклади ще не
означають енергетичної незалежності.
Досягти її можна, але лише за умови що українська
влада знизить рівень корупції та усуне олігархів
від впливу на галузь.
Що у короткостроковій перспективі виглядає не реалістично.